free freedom how's your relationship  with him because he's like one of the  nicest dudes oh yeah i mean i've been  doing it's crazy i knew him when he was  still in school like  he used to call me for to get a job  trying to get a job he's like such a  nice dude you know something i don't  know how to be wrapped up in some [ __ ]  you know but like when i brought he cool  i'm like man this dude got his head  like i said  i watched when he first graduated from  high school and they he  you know ended up taking off  and when he when he blew up you know he  ain't changed he ain't changed at all  you know he called me out to the miami  you know invited me to the house gave my  own room and there when i knew i was  done you know so